hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast enrichment of CFS DNA and
CT DNA via size selection for reduced
diagnostic mistake on presented by dr.
mapping as the president of coastal
genomics
I'm Cindy Valdez of Lavery's and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational virtual conference presented
by labyrinth the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
here's how the presentation will work
today we want to hear from you questions
comments and even cancers can be
submitted via the Q&A button at the
lower left of your sprint we're trying
to get to everyone but if not I'll make
sure to follow up with you but you know
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon on the lower
right hand corner of your slide window
if you cannot hear or see this
presentation robbery let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button at the lower
left this is an educational webinar and
offers free continuing educational
credits after the webinar is going on
please click on the CC button located at
the bottom left hand corner of your
webpage and follow the process for
obtaining your credit without further
adieu I'd like to prevent and introduce
today's speaker dr. mapping advocate
welcome sir thank you very much Susie
and thank you very much for taking the
time to listen to me to talk today about
the opportunities that are being
explored out there as well as new
methods for the enrichment of self
repealed a DNA and circling tumor DNA
without further ado I will launch into
presentation so a little bit on cell
free DNA and what it is a cell free DNA
is
is a DNA that is sourced from cells that
are inside the body that have died in
our being recycled the DNA is broken
down and it ends up in the circulatory
system so that means that the cell-free
DNA stems from all sorts of tissues in
the body obviously this means things
such as normal tissues shed cells that
contribute to the cell-free DNA or CF
DNA pool as do any possible tumors that
actually reside in an individual and in
the case of a pregnant mother a fetus
too will shed DNA and it will contribute
to that cell-free DNA pool
this means that through a blood draw one
could potentially sequence DNA from all
these tissue types and that would allow
the the doctor or anyone else who is
actually conducting any research to find
things such as the presence of the tumor
or learn about what the genetic
characteristics are of the fetus without
necessitating an invasive procedure
which has been a standard to date for
such work now cell-free DNA work is new
it is in something that is coming along
for the utility with fetal diagnostics
and as far as being used as a diagnostic
for tumors that it is something that is
still in development and one of the
issues with the utilization of cell-free
DNA for Diagnostics is that we really
suffer from the needle in the haystack
problem what we mean by that is that
cell-free DNA fragments that originate
from a fetus or a tumor are really
greatly outnumbered by all those
cell-free DNA fragments that originate
from normal tissue this means that in
any liquid biopsy you would have to
query a large number of
normal uninteresting cell-free DNA
fragments for every single fragment you
get from a tissue that you're interested
in characterizing furthermore you know
the one way to actually deal with that
is to try to get a bit of cell free DNA
fragments that originate from normal
tissues but there are situations in
which such a process can lead to the
erroneous discarding of fragments from a
fetus or tumor in situations where there
are not very many of these types of
fragments the result can be a false
negative result and in such a situation
recovery of all available so-called
needles would be critical in order to be
able to determine the presence of a
paternalist a streamer for example or to
be able to render a diagnostic on an
annually associated with fetus so
cell-free DNA testing obviously can
either be costly or lack diagnostic
sensitivity cell-free fetal DNA testing
right now is a costly procedure compared
to standards of care and we are seeing
an actual increase even with this huge
relative cost of this test in 2016
out of 210 million insurance policy
covering us lives 90 million of those
included coverage for cell-free DNA
testing associated with average risk
pregnancies that represents a 60% growth
over the year but it can still be quite
costly compared to standard care options
and based on handling some pieces or
chorionic villus sampling and there are
there's a real need to actually drop the
cost of this test in order to make it
accessible to all and the way that right
now these costs are minimized is to
actually take advantage of so-called a
large-scale economy of scale sequencing
so what we mean by this is instead of
every hospital being able to conduct
this sequencing on all the pregnant
mothers in the maternity ward these
samples are normally and shipped to
major hubs in the world that end up
being able to benefit from the lower
cost per base they're associated with
high-throughput sequencing the problem
then becomes that shipping becomes a
hurdle to dropping the cost when you
have patients that are having blood
samples sent from all over the world to
either the San Francisco Bay Area or
Hong Kong then that FedEx cost becomes a
barrier to being a to this being tested
is actually at a price point that makes
it accessible to everybody so that is a
little bit of discussion on the issue of
cost and what the reality is of it and
of course as I also mentioned there is
the issue of sensitivity and as well as
how do we actually get rid of all the
fragments that stem from normal tissues
that end up dragging at the cost of
these assays so there are a number of
technologies that exist on the market
today that try to answer this question
I'm just going to go over a couple of
them right here the first one that I
talked about is the on target platform
this is a solution provided by boreal
genomics which is a private area system
that exposes a cell-free DNA sample to
an agarose gel and the agarose gel it
has a lawn of affixed probes that are
complementary to mutations that are
desired to be isolated from the normal
cell free DNA fragments the on target
platform uses a process known as skoda
and the continual binding events between
target molecules and the affixed probes
ends up leading to a discrepancy in the
direction of travel generated by
the electro phoretic skoda assay and
this ends up leading to a number of
binding events and add basically a means
of actually separating normal fragments
from to your fragments the the process
is very efficient it can enrich no
mutant alleles over a million fold from
what they would otherwise have been at
without any processing and the yield is
also relatively high and typically being
over 50% and so this is a fantastic way
to be able to enrich mutants that were
known and sought out before the actual
experiment started the drawback here is
just that fact that you do have to know
what that mutation is in order to be
able to appropriately design the probes
that are affixed to the gel long and of
course in certain situations there were
being no preconceived notion as to what
the type of tumour is what you're
looking for and thus I think this might
be a little bit narrow in scope for some
applications so backing out and
broadening the scope a little bit there
are other solutions that take a less
specific approach the the capsid system
which was a comes from the Stanford
laboratories of Max teen and actually
zeday this this is an option that was
actually acquired by Brooks and has been
marketed as the Ivania kit and it's a
based on a target capture and they
combined the bond dramatics method to it
to generate a highly specific highly
sensitive test for cell free tumor DNA
the method basically takes advantage of
a selector probe set which is used as a
bait for different genetic elements that
are desired to be isolated from
the rest of the DNA associated with the
cell for example this approach is a
little bit different than that taken by
the on target platform what's going on
here is that there are certain genetic
recurrent mutations associated with
genes or other elements that are
understood and characterized through
population wide screening and the actual
test as it is applied to an individual
will use a selector probe set that was
found to be ideal for pulling out
genetic elements associated current
mutations and isolating them from
everything else so what this means is
that you're getting specific genes may
be it may be depress the p53 gene and
you're getting all of the mutated as
well as the normal versions of it so
there is still a increased cost because
you're sequencing through normal DNA but
the isolation event does greatly drop
the cost of the assay and the reported
sensitivity of these essays by the
authors has gone all the way down to
point zero two percent however the the
Ivania kit itself is not reporting such
sensitivity I believe that that is
actually more 104 percent and that's a
result of the fact that to achieve the
point zero two percent sensitivity a
very costly sequencing operation is
required but then again the other
benefit of this is that instead of
looking for a specific point mutation in
the p53 gene the cap seek approach can
take the entire p53 gene which can then
be sequenced and look for mutations
which could it was the progression of a
tumor
so there are also continually new
discoveries about what the
characteristics are associated with
cell-free DNA both when groups are
looking into you utilizing for fetal
diagnostics as well as to your
Diagnostics this slide here goes over a
finding by the Dennis low group here
where it was realized that there is
actually a size discrepancy between
cell-free DNA fragments that stem from
fetus and those that stem from the
mother as you can see in the graph on
the right hand side here blue line
actually represents the Trident length
distribution profile for the fetal
component of the cell-free DNA profile
whereas the red line shows the average
between both the maternal and fetal
contributions there's an average
difference between these two of roughly
22 base pairs and of course this
actually opens the door to a different
method of enrichment namely gel based
science collection this would require a
very tight size selection in order to be
able to recover as much of the fetal
component while rejecting as much of the
maternal component however if you could
do this there appears that there would
be room for relative enrichment of CF
DNA over the normal seat over with
normal material in the cell-free DNA
component other findings also appear to
suggest a size specific bias for
fragments that originated from tumors a
group at the University of Utah led by
dr. hunter Underhill actually set out to
characterize such potential for
enrichment via a very tight size
selection enabled by polyacrylamide gel
electrophoresis as you can see in the
graphic on right here doctor Underhill
ended up fractionating a cell-free
profile into numerous different size
ranges and then went about a digital PCR
experiment that was meant to
characterize the relative ratio of
mutant allele frequencies so to speak
associated with the unsigned selected
portion as well as all the different
fractions in the size selection itself
as we can see here in the see diagram on
the far left this digital PCR experiment
found what without size selection the
mutant allele frequency registered at
about one-third of one percent the other
mutant allele frequency graph to the
right of this one on the left here show
that we actually have variable nuke
allele frequencies some that are lower
than the on-site ones but some that are
actually quite higher to actually as
high as a tenfold in terms of an
enrichment over the unselected fraction
what we can do as you can see with this
graph representing the actual unselected
portion here we find that there was a
size selection as well that allow for
enrichment of the v-moda frequency all
the way up to 3 percent so it seems like
side selection on a very very tight
basis can potentially be used to
increase the level of these mutant
alleles over the allele over cell free
DNA fragments that stem from normal
tissues so to consider gel size
selection as an option for this requires
us to think a little bit about exactly
what the implications are so the reasons
to consider it are that it can
potentially increase the ratio of
mutants pregnant or fetal fragments over
the normal frame
that come to dominate the cell free
sample cell free DNA sample this of
course can be treated sequencing costs
because we do not have the sequence of
many normal cell free DNA fragments
before we get to those friends that stem
from a fetus or from a tumor the other
potential benefit is that it is sequence
independent being that because it is
just a side selection is based on the
fragment length there is no requirement
to understand what the nutation was
beforehand in order to develop a date
approach in order to recover fragments
associated with two years or with
fetuses however there are drawbacks to
this as well the size selection that is
required and that was used by the group
at the University Utah is tedious the
University of Utah has X reported that
it took two full days to actually
conduct the polyacrylamide gel size
selection which enables highly accurate
very tight size selection this of course
would not translate well to a clinical
environment where numerous samples are
being processed every day the other
drawback of this is that it is possible
that through a size selection like this
that not all pregnant sprinters land in
the region of interest and that we would
be discarding them and in such a
situation if we had very few fragments
of interest to begin with we could end
up discarding fragments that matter and
then generating false negative results
so to think a little bit about that last
point about where does it really hurt us
if we're just doing a side selection on
a sample of cell-free DNA this graph
here shows a little bit of the
relationship between and disease state
or gestational phase along with the
relative amount of cell-free fetal DNA
or circulating tumor DNA obviously when
we're taking a look at early detection
of tumors or prior to the end of the
first trimester of a pregnancy you have
very very few fragments relative to
normal cell free DNA fragments into any
blood draw or any other liquid biopsy
however when we look at later disease
states or as the fetus ages the amount
of cell free DNA that's contributed by
either a tumor orpheus is increased with
respect to normal cell free DNA so again
so here at the early stage it's very
likely that there's too few mutant
allele frequency for size selection to
be something that would be really
considered as a viable option here
simply because we may be throwing out
everything with such a general size
selection however when you take a look
at some of the other applications as in
cell 3 fetal DNA testing that's where
the end of the first trimester or a
treatment selection on possibly
surveillance of a disease state there
are a relatively higher number of
fragments that are non normal origin and
this increases the chance of us being
able to use size selection to drop the
cost of the essay while not reducing the
sensitivity to a point that makes the
whole effort worthless
so now I'm going to introduce to you
coastal genomics Ranger technology this
is a automated option that is a leading
in its class or highly accurate
repeatable gel based size selection
rangy technology it comes in two
permutations right now the first is the
Nimbus select this is a fully automated
liquid handling workstation it comes
equipped with Ranger technology use
hardware platform as well as it's
machine vision software outfit the light
bench is due to be released later this
year and it will be featuring range of
technology on a scaled-down basis in a
modular box which can be integrated with
liquid handling robots or it can also be
leveraged by bench technicians so I'm
going to be moving into the next few
slides here to talk a little bit about
what Ranger technology is and what can
be accomplished with it this slide right
here shows the deck layout of the Nimbus
select as we can see here at the front
and rear of the instrument we have what
are known as electrophoresis pedestals
so the first one is outlined in yellow
here and second one is back right here
the middle here at hosts a DNA source
plate which is used to house the DNA
sample as well as a loading buffer with
a bright airy marker mixture a source
with it the this mixture of samples is
loaded into the gel cassette which are
loaded onto the electrophoresis
pedestals automatically find the liquid
Handler and when the size selection
event is complete size selected
fractions are reformatted to a second
target plate here which is then ready
for downstream processing so this
represents the first part of the
hardware component of a new technology
being
to electrophoresis pencils the second
income hardware component of Ranger
technology involves some mounted
components that on the gantry of the
robot specifically a camera that is used
for capturing images of the jello
cassettes and the DNA as it's being
electrophoresis a illumination stage is
also attached in order to cause dye
molecules that are in the llowing buffer
and bound to DNA to fluoresce this
fluorescence is the signal that is
captured by the camera we will also note
that the lighting array uses two
different colors right now a blue light
and a red light the blue light is used
to excite cyber gold which binds
globally 12 DNA in the sample the red
lightning while is used to excite a
secondary dye molecule which is
exclusively attached to a to marker
system that is loaded with every sample
this marker system is critical for the
real-time assessment of electro phoretic
mobility that is going to be conducted
in every single channel and this allows
us to actually realize air and take it
and take control of any differences
between samples that may alter the
mobility of being a true and electro
phoretic laneway such variables include
temperature ionic strength and pH
this animation here will highlight for
you exactly how the Nemus select
conducts its work with range technology
so at the outset we assume that we have
a source plate DNA sample and our
loading buffer with the marker mixture
all together in a source plate the
liquid handling manifold then comes down
and aspirates this mixture out of source
plate the liquid handling manifold then
moves over to one of the standard
agarose cassettes which is a very simple
in design the cassette is comprised of
liquid buffer reservoirs and the distal
ends of the cassette and in the middle
we have an agarose block with 12
physically isolated channels running
down the length of the actual cassette
also the there are preformed loading and
extraction wells associated with every
of these 12 channels here and we'll see
how living handler interfaces with those
shortly here non-apple deposits the
mixture of DNA sample and the loading
buffer into the loading wells and at
this point the electrophoresis is
initiated and what is going to happen
now is that the camera that's not to
began she is going to take pictures of
the entire cassette hopefully once every
couple of minutes and we're going to
taking pictures with the red light
turned on in order to be able to
visualize our marker system and you'll
see that there's two markers in every
channel then we're going to be taking
pictures with the blue light turned on
in order to be able to see the actual
DNA sample itself so once every couple
of minutes that the picture is captured
and the software measures the mobility
of the DNA sample in every channel and
also identifies where the target is in
every channel because the target is not
necessarily the same in every channel
and
and by doing this it can understand
exactly what the relative mobility is of
every sample in this cassette and alter
the voltage to manipulate that mobility
in a way that allows for the synchronous
arrival of target fractions at a
downstream extraction well once that has
taken place the manifold comes down
aspirates out the sample and deposits it
into a target or destination blade for
further processing so what's really
happened here is that there has been an
ongoing real-time assessment of mobility
of DNA samples for each of 12 samples
this allows for highly accurate
repeatable size selection little bit now
on how this is actually what this
actually results in the precision of the
Ranger technology size selection again
is based on real-time tracking of
mobility changes of every sample on so
that the exact target that is desired
can be recovered
every time this secures a collection of
desired fraction at the point of
extraction because we're able to
manipulate the exact point or the exact
voltages applied to every sample and we
can drive it exact to the exact point in
the world we want to for extraction this
as we can see here on the bottom I led
to a very consistent size selection over
a number of samples that as
characterized by a fragment analyzer
readout of a samples that gone through
size selection with Ranger technology
there are other options for solution as
well that our viable options however
most of them are based on line scanning
technologies which basically measure the
mobility of DNA at a single cord in a
cassette what this means though is that
should that mobility change at a point
past the first assessment of mobility
then there will be a slight deviation
between what the desired recovered
fraction was and what the actual of the
proper fraction ends up becoming this
can lead to a slight variation between
samples as to what's recovered due to
the very discrete nature and high
resolution and accuracy that was
required by the University of Utah in
order to obtain their tenfold enrichment
of reading allele frequencies such a
deviation would not result in a
repeatable method for enriching for
these mutant allele fragments range of
technology also brings the benefit of
very high accuracy because we are in
conducting an analysis on the whole
channel we can take advantage of two
markers simultaneously to interpolate
between them to actually come up with a
very accurate estimate on what the size
of the target can be between them the
accuracy specification associated range
technology is 5% however very often the
at the error is associated it is much
lower than this and furthermore because
the system uses long electro phoretic
laneways we are able to achieve a very
impressive resolution that is on par
with polyacrylamide gel size collection
as can be seen on the right here
fragments that differ by only 10 base
pairs can be isolated from each other
and therefore extracted from each other
by the time they arrive at the
extraction well this sort of resolution
is right on par with what was used in
polyacrylamide gel size collection by
the University of Utah and it also
affords in very impressive intrinsic
recovery yield typically above eighty
percent of the material that is found
within the target range
so again talk about the utility of gel
size selection as it can be applied to
cell-free fetal DNA or circulating to
your DNA we have to consider a number of
realities associated with this new field
that is exciting in promises to play a
part in all of our lives as we as we age
and as we go through life the first is
that gel size selection does not the
potential to draw sequencing costs the
size selection enrichment that brings up
the relative level of cell reveal DNA or
circulating tumor DNA however it should
be noted that this is likely not a good
option for all applications it would
only be applicable to samples with
non-negligible
levels of mutant allele frequencies
selphie fetal DNA testing is typically
done at the end of the first trimester
at a point where that relative with that
ratio is at about a 10% level and this
is sufficient to be able to go through a
tight size selection for the purpose of
dropping the cost of the assay while
ensuring that there is still a
reasonable amount of that material in
order to conduct a diagnostic assay
other applications associated with
certain turn your DNA testing are yet to
be decided upon certainly early stage a
tumor testing may or may not be
something that is Bible given the low
mutant allele frequency low however
certain disease states and perhaps when
the patient is at a spot where treatment
selection is necessary these these sorts
of applications where there is increased
the mutant low-frequency load may allow
themselves to have the assay cost drop
via gel size selection furthermore by
utilizing gel size solution for self
repeal DNA testing we are opening the
door potentially to groups not having to
ship samples from all over the world to
hubs in San Francisco or Hong Kong or
wherever they may be
this is really being enabled by the fact
that through reduced sequencing cost
that per base pair cost associated with
these smaller benchtop sequences that
are out there and now become competitive
and by doing so that absolved me for
costly shipping around the world of
these sounds so to summarize here range
e technology can be used to repeatedly
isolate type DNA fraction ranges and it
does come into the format Nimbus Select
can run up to 96 isolation per run and
while the life dance right now can run
up to 8 samples per run but can
integrate with any Hamilton live a
family robot to automate process of
assay plate setup or to set unloading or
living it is also also has the
flexibility of being able to work with
an edge technician as well should that
be the route someone wants to take and
with that I would like to thank
everybody for your time and for your
questions thank you dr. Anstead for that
informative presentation and we do you
want to begin now with our Q&A segment
so here's our reminders - audience
members how you can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left of the screen
if we're unable to get your questions
due to time constraints dr. Anne has
volunteered to cancer any submitted
questions via email so let's take a look
at our first question of the day doctor
visits an audience member was like you
know minted University of Utah find that
the fragment link over which there was
significant enrichment say the same for
different tumor types
thank you very much for the question
the findings in the paper that was
published in June last year were from a
small sample set where this only
glioblastoma and lung cancer samples
were looked at on a small basis the
findings right now are inconclusive on
whether the size range is the same
throughout different cancer types or
even if there's a difference in the
progression or stage of a tumor
follow-up work is being conducted and
hopefully answers to these questions
will be coming a maybe in the near
future thank you for that answer
and here's another question can be
compete the approaches we used to enrich
for CFS DNA or CT DNA
thank you
v based approaches are viable means of
size selection for a number of
sequencing applications and when they
can be leveraged they should because
they are highly amenable Automation
right now as far as their application
for enrichment of cell-free fetal DNA or
circulating tumor DNA samples the early
thinking is that the the ability to
effectively discriminate over a tight
range using beads is not something that
is compatible with what the requirements
would be for enrichment using a size
selection gel size selection has the
advantage of being able to get a good
yield out of a size selection that what
there's hard to be extremely narrow in
terms of size and if you'll recall from
the slide that highlighted the work of
you
did Utah in order to actually tease out
the different fractions and find that
one that had an enrichment on the order
of ten fold they required a
polyacrylamide gel size selection where
the size range that you're getting is on
the are on the on the range of a plus or
minus 10 base pairs such a tight range
should that be soft with be based on
selection would most likely yield in
next to zero percent recovery beads are
more effective at other applications
such as next arrow library preparation
or PCR free library preparation as of
today it appears that size selection for
enrichment on these as cell free or
these circulating to your DNA samples
will require the strategy is so the
stringency afforded by a type gel based
size selection thank you again dr.
Nesbitt and thank you for the important
research that you're doing do you have
any closing remarks you'd like to share
with the audience before we leave today
yeah sure just to just to sum up here
obviously cell-free fetal DNA testing or
serves as a real boon in terms of being
able to be used as that non basic
prenatal diagnostic tool and we've seen
a growing adoption of this tool because
it's board's pregnant mothers a lot of
comfort and the positive predictive
value of the test seems to be one that
is being a very valuable in terms of
putting a lot of people at ease on the
front of circulating Turner DNA there
are groups that are doing testing with
this right now obviously it was the
future is we are told is going to
include a reality where individuals have
their blood tested every other year in
order to be able to detect the presence
Real Estate's tumors and it's such a
reality where to ever come then it would
be interesting indeed because be able
the ability to identify tumors at stage
1 stage 2 presence decades potentially
before the otherwise would have been
detected should allow the medical
community to be able to act quickly and
help to drop the cost of health care
that is associated with later stage 2
your treatments thank you again dr.
Matthew mystic I would also like to
thank
laboratory today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August 2017 keep an eye out for an email
from libraries sharing you in this
webcast will be available for replay we
encourage you to forward this
announcement to your colleagues to me as
miss today's live event thank you again
for joining us and hope to see you again
next time
Devine